[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Hello, and
welcome to Google I/O 2017.
I hope everybody had
a great first day
and got to check out some of
the sessions, the sandboxes
and the codelabs.
I'm Chris Ramsdale, the
lead product manager
for the Google Assistant SDK.
GLEN SHIRES: And I'm Glen
Shires, technical lead
for the Google Assistant SDK.
CHRIS RAMSDALE:
Today, we want to talk
to you about one ubiquitous
Google Assistant experience
that utilizes many of the
devices in your everyday life.
Back at I/O last year,
the Google Assistant
made its debut in the form
of integration with Allo.
And while much of the technology
that makes up the Assistant
had been in the
works for years--
things like voice search,
automated speech recognition,
natural language understanding--
while they'd been in
the works for years,
it was the first time that
they'd made their public debut
in the form of the Assistant.
Now, since then, the teams
have been hard at work
to flesh out the story
that Google wants to tell,
in terms of launching new
devices like the Google
Home, the Pixel, and
other Android platforms.
And we've also brought
third-party services
into the fold, via
Actions on Google,
as well as home automation
devices and services
in terms of technologies like
the Home Graph and Smarthome
agents which I'll
talk about in a bit.
And while this was great,
when we took a step back,
we realized something
was missing.
See at Google, especially
within the Assistant team,
one of our missions
is to help you
with whatever you want, wherever
you want, wherever you are.
We managed to bring some of the
fundamental services to you,
be it news, podcasts,
home automation, weather,
but they were only
available from devices
that Google provided.
Now, let's be honest.
We don't expect you
to have a Google
Home in every corner
of your house,
nor do we expect
Google to provide
every appliance in your house.
In order to meet you
whenever you needed it,
wherever you need it, we needed
to empower a diverse ecosystem
of third-party
device manufacturers
that were able to embed the
Google Assistant in the devices
they were building.
Just as Actions
on Google enables
you to extend the Assistant to
include third-party services,
we needed an analogous
offering on the device side.
We needed a way to allow
device manufacturers
to embed the Assistant
and to extend
it to control the devices.
Enter the Google
Assistant SDK, which
we launched three weeks ago.
It does just that.
It's a software development kit
that allows third party device
manufacturers to embed the
Assistant in their device.
At its core is a
gRPC API that allows
you to access the Assistant
from any platform.
Along with that comes
documentation, samples,
and tools to get
started quickly.
The API itself is an
audio in, audio out API.
It allows you to
build hardware where
users can interact with the
Assistant in a general form--
hey, Google, how big is Mt.
Everest?-- to a personal form--
hey, Google, what's
on my calendar today--
to working with any other
third-party services
that have extended the
assistant via Actions on Google.
And given the fact
that the API is
built on the gRPC
protocol, which
is optimized for
bidirectional streaming,
you can be sure that your
audio flows smoothly and is
processed quickly.
And while it was only
announced three weeks ago,
we've already seen a lot of
cool innovation happening
within the communities.
For starters, we have
a Mocktails Mixer
out on Main Street
that I encourage you
to come out to see a demo of.
It's a collaboration between
the Google Assistant SDK team
and a creative agency
called Deeplocal.
And it's a mixer that has
the Google Assistant built in
and will bring you any
drink of your choice.
We're also seeing other ideas
within the startup communities,
everything from
the AutoPi.io folks
which have instructions
for how to embed
the assistant on
like a prototype car,
to what appears to be a
Wi-Fi enabled smart rabbit.
For those of you
who would rather
have a smart rabbit in your
house than a Google Home,
you now have options.
But seriously, beyond
that we're also
working with commercial
OEMs to embed
the Assistant in their devices.
And over the coming
months, we'll
have commercial terms, things
like device certification
programs, branding
guidelines and UX guidelines.
Speaking of spurring
innovation, another program
that we launched was
called AIY, similar
to the do-it-yourself
communities which is DIY.
AIY aims to bring artificial
intelligence to the Maker
Toolkit, allowing them to build
devices that help both them
and their communities.
At the core of the program is a
set of kits that you can build.
The first kit that
we rolled out was
a voice kit that comes with
the Google Assistant SDK,
as well as a button, a
speaker, a cardboard box,
and instructions for making
your own makeshift Google Home
that we hope you extend in
ways that we never dreamed of.
You may notice one up here.
Right up here.
Glen will be doing demos
on it very shortly.
So that's what we've
launched, and I
want to talk a little
bit more about what
we're launching today.
So as of yesterday, we've
added a thick client library
to the SDK that does things
like automate a lot of the lower
level plumbing, as
well as give you
client-side functionality
in terms of Hotword support
and timers and alarms.
With the addition
of this library,
developers now have options.
If you want more
automation or if you
need Hotword support
or timers and alarms,
we think the Google Assistant
library, that thick client
library, is a good fit.
You just need to be
comfortable with embedded Linux
and an [? RMD-7 ?] chipset,
because the client side code is
tied to that particular
platform and that hardware.
On the other hand, if you favor
or need platform independence,
we think the gRPC
API is a great route.
As I had mentioned, it's
accessible from any platform,
any hardware, any
language, with the caveat
that it doesn't
have the client side
support of Hotwords, timers and
alarms, but that's just now.
And I want to take a
moment to actually preview
some of the tools that
we're building to make voice
control of devices much easier.
Now, Glen's going
to have a demo,
and we also have demos
over in Sandbox B of this,
but I thought I'd take a moment
to provide a higher level
view so you can
understand broadly
what we're trying to achieve
here with more devices
being in your life having
the assistant on them.
See, first it's important
to know what devices you
have access to in your house--
be it the TV, or a
speaker, an oven,
or that Wi-Fi smart
enabled rabbit
that we just talked about.
By knowing what devices
we have access to,
or what you have access
to in your house,
we can actually
enable and create
more natural conversations
with those devices.
And we think that's very
important, because if we don't
get this right, this
whole voice enabled thing
that we're trying to
all do and make happen,
it's going to be very hard
for the masses to adopt it.
You want to have
normal conversations
with the things
in your life just
like the people in your life.
So by knowing what devices
you have access to,
we can make the
conversation more natural.
So instead of
saying, for example,
if you had a smart enabled
oven, and you're in your living
room talking to your Google
Home, instead of saying,
hey, Google, let me
talk to my company,
my company, set
the oven to bake,
set the oven to 425, what
you can do is say OK Google,
set the oven to bake at 425.
Just as you would
if you are talking
to your child or
your wife or somebody
else that happened to
be in your kitchen.
It's more natural.
Second of all, when I move from
being in my living room talking
to my Google Home and now
I've moved to my kitchen,
say I'm preparing
dinner, I'm actually
talking to the
device itself, which
if you had to talk to the
device itself and say,
hey, Google, let me talk to my
company, set the oven to bake,
set the temperature to 425,
that's really odd when you're
talking to the device.
What you want to be able
to do while you're chopping
the carrots and potatoes
is simply say, OK Google,
set to bake at 425.
You end up having more natural
conversations whether you're
talking to the Google Home
to work with the device,
you're talking to
the device itself.
So that's the end
user experience--
that's the beginning of
the end user experience
that we're trying to achieve.
But let's take a second
to go a little bit deeper
and talk about how that
actually would work.
So take the case
where you're actually
doing remote invocation.
You're talking to
the Google Home
which is setting up the oven.
In that case you say,
OK Google, set the oven
to bake at 425 degrees.
So that query goes from
me to my Google Home
then to the Assistant
Service running.
That Assistant
Service is made up
of speech recognition, natural
language understanding,
the Smarthome, and a technology
we call the Home Graph.
So what it can do is it can
take that query, what I said,
and start to parse it apart.
And when it parses it apart,
the speech recognition
actually talks to the
Home Graph and says,
hey, do you recognize any of
these pieces in this phrase?
And the Home Graphs
says, I actually do.
I recognize the oven as being
a device that's been registered
with the Home Graph.
The way it gets registered
is when you'd actually
go to your home device
and on the Assistant app
on your phone you
could say, I want
to add that to my Home
Graph, and it would walk you
through that flow.
So now, the Home Graph
says, I understand
that that's the oven.
So the speech recognition
says, that's great.
So I've got the oven,
which is the noun,
the thing I'm trying
to operate on,
and then I've got these
other things that look
like verbs and nouns as well.
And it passes that over to the
natural language understanding,
that service.
It takes that and says
to the Home Graph,
do you understand what it means
to set this program, which is
bake, and set this temperature?
And the Home Graph says yes.
The oven is capable of these
certain traits, programs
that are like bake and warm and
broil, and then temperatures,
and that's a number.
So at that point in time, the
natural language understanding
can say cool, I understand
not only what they said,
but what they intended.
But it says, I have no
idea what to do with this.
I've got an intent, but I
don't know what to do with it.
So it sends that over
to the Smarthome,
and the Smarthome
says, cool, I got this.
I actually know what
to do with this intent.
I know that the
oven is of this type
and tied to this manufacturer.
And this manufacturer actually
has a third-party cloud
and knows how to actually get
the intent down to the device.
To give you a concrete
example, this is very analogous
if you have say a Nest
thermostat in your home.
You're talking to
the Google Home,
the Google Home does
all this processing,
and at the end of it,
the Smarthome component
hands it off to the Nest
cloud, and the Nest cloud says,
I know how to actually query the
device for what temperature it
is, or to set the
temperature on the device.
So I apologize.
This actually says
local execution path.
This is the remote
invocation path
where I'm actually
controlling the device when
I'm not talking to the device.
So let's talk about
how you actually would
do the local invocation path.
So again, this is when I'm in
the kitchen talking to my oven.
I say, OK Google, set
to bake at 425 degrees.
Now that query comes
back in the same path,
but notice I didn't
say the oven.
So the speech recognition,
it gets the query.
It's missing the oven piece,
but what it actually gets
is some bit of metadata,
which is the device ID.
That comes from the Assistant
being embedded on the oven,
picking up the
query, figuring out
what device it's coming from
and passing it up to our cloud.
So the speech
recognition says, look,
I got this set to
bake at 425 degrees,
but I also got this device ID.
Home Graph, do you know
what to do with this?
And in a very similar
fashion, the Home Graph
says, oh yes, I
recognize that device ID.
It's tied to this manufacturer,
and it's this thing.
It's an oven.
So now, the speech
recognition has
the same fundamental
building blocks,
through local
invocation, that it
did through remote invocation.
So it can pass it on to the
NLU the Natural Language
Understanding,
and the NLU can do
the same thing it did before,
and then it passes it over
to the Smarthome.
Now, at this point in time,
things twist a little bit.
The Smarthome says,
OK, I understand
what the user-- the intent
of the user, but that intent
came from an interaction
with a device,
because the Smarthome gets
the device ID as well.
And so when it talks to the
Home Graph, the Home Graph goes,
you can send that back
down to the device.
You don't have to go
through a third-party cloud.
So what the Smarthome
does is it sends back down
to the device the audio, so
setting oven to 425 degrees,
as well as the structured
response in terms
of a JSON payload back
down to the device.
The device can say, cool.
Actually, when it
sends it to the device,
it's sending to the Assistant
that's embedded on the device.
And the Assistant
picks it up it says,
I don't know what
to do with this,
but let me see if I
have a module that's
actually registered to
handle this response.
Do, do, do, do, do.
I do.
Calls that on the device,
and that code actually
sets the oven to
bake at 425 degrees.
Now, to the end user this
is great, because again,
it creates a natural
conversation no matter
where you are in your home.
And while I gave an
example of just one device,
fast forward two to five years.
Imagine a whole bunch of devices
in your home that are listening
and you're
interacting with them.
If you have odd
conversations, that's
just not going to work
out in your favor.
So that's what's good from the
user experience perspective.
From the developer perspective
and from the device
manufacturer's perspective,
you get code reuse.
The same code that's
being executed
when I'm talking to my home
device back down to the oven
is the same code that's running
when I'm talking directly
to my device.
So if it's a developer
you get code reuse.
That's good.
As a device
manufacturer, the benefit
is that it's a shorter
path to getting to market,
because you don't
have to have a cloud
presence to have the
Assistant running on a device.
So if your goal is to make
the devices that you're
building smarter by embedding
the Assistant on them,
you can go to local
invocation route
and simply put
code on the device
and let the Assistant, our
speech recognition, NLU,
Smarthome, and Home Graph handle
all this stuff in the cloud,
because as you notice
on this screen,
there is no cloud presence.
We've dropped the
yellow bit that was
on the remote invocation path.
So we think that's great that as
a developer you get code reuse,
and as a device manufacturer
that you get a shorter time
to market.
So OK, enough with
the high level stuff.
I'm going to turn it over
to Glen to do some demos
and talk about some code.
GLEN SHIRES: All right,
thank you very much Chris.
I appreciate that.
[APPLAUSE]
So as Chris mentioned,
yesterday, we
announced the Hotword Library
that is available for download.
So you can start
experimenting with it
and start building it into
your project and products.
What I'd like to do
is demonstrate that,
jump right into a demo.
OK Google, what sound
does a whale make?
GOOGLE: Here's a whale sound.
[WHALE SOUND]
GLEN SHIRES: OK Google,
what's 18% of $57?
GOOGLE: The answer is $10.26.
GLEN SHIRES: OK Google,
add peanut butter
to my shopping list.
GOOGLE: OK, I've added peanut
butter to your shopping list.
GLEN SHIRES: So there you go.
So what we've done is we have
created a library that you
can download and make it
really easy to incorporate OK
Google into your projects,
as well as including
the timers, alarms,
and other things.
I'm sorry, it should have been--
could we show this
one more time?
I'm sorry, let's
go back to that.
What I wanted to do is show
you exactly what I had here.
This is a Raspberry
Pi, and I simply
have a microphone, a single
microphone, and a speaker,
plugged into a Raspberry
Pi, a power supply,
and ethernet because Wi-Fi in
here is a little bit tricky.
But that would work
on Wi-Fi as well.
So basically, we just simply
have a speaker, a microphone,
and an internet
connection, and that's
all we need to implement
the capability of farfield,
activation of the Hotword,
and to implement basic Google
Assistant.
So let me show you exactly
what is in the library.
What's really cool is it's
extremely simple to use.
This client library, you only
need to call a few method
calls to make it work.
Actually, you can
only call one method
if you want to, just call
start, and it will just
run autonomously,
waiting locally
to listen for the Hotword,
OK Google, and then when
it hears that, it
will take the audio,
send it up to the Google
servers for processing.
And when the audio comes
back, it will play that.
So if that's all you want
to do, just call start
and you're done, literally.
There's a few other
things you can do.
For example, you might want to
have a button on your device
that mutes the microphone.
So you can call that
mute the microphone.
Turn that on and off.
Or also, you may want to have
a button or a remote control
where you activate it by
pushing rather than saying,
OK Google, or Hey
Google as the Hotword.
And so you can call
start interaction.
We also have a number
of events that come out
as it's processing so that
you can watch the status
and perhaps have lights that
indicate the current status.
For example,
conversation turn started
means somebody said,
OK Google, and you've
begun that conversation.
End of utterance means
the person has finished
talking, and recognizing speech
finished means the server has
finished recognizing the speech,
and then responding started
is actually talking back to
you, responding finished.
So you can set up light bulbs
or whatever that indicate
the status as it's going along.
There's also alert
started, finish,
so for timers and alarms.
So number of events that
you can handle or not,
depending on what exactly you'd
like to do with your device.
So let me show you
another option,
and this is basically
an option that if you
want to do something
that's very minimal,
or if you want more flexibility
and you don't need a Hotword,
we have other options as well,
which is in this case, a way
that you can make remote
procedure calls directly
against the server.
So it's minimal
processing on the board.
In this case, I actually
have a Raspberry Pi Zero,
which is a $5 or $10 retail
product, which is really
all you need to do this,
because all it's doing
is sending audio to the
cloud and getting audio back.
It's not doing any
processing here.
And this is also very portable
to most platforms, most
operating systems, and
most programming languages,
and completely open source.
So what we have
with this is a way
to talk to the cloud,
the Google cloud,
called gRPC or Remote
Procedure Calls,
and these remote procedure calls
run on nearly any platform.
So you could easily port these--
well, they're already on Linux,
Mac, Windows, Android, iPhone,
already supporting languages
of C, Go, Python, Node.js, PHP,
Ruby, and there's
an open tool chain
that you can easily port
these to any other platform.
The thing about it is, it's a
nice, robust protocol, error
handling protocol, that also
allows bidirectional streaming.
So what that means is, you could
be sending audio to the server
while the server is
sending information back.
And when the server
is responding,
obviously you can continue
to send things up.
So it's a
bidirectional protocol,
and it's available
for any platform.
So what I'd like to do
is demonstrate this.
And in this case, I
actually have the voice kit
that Chris was
talking about, which
is all the pieces you
need to build this.
Of course, if you
want to just have
a speaker and a microphone,
you can do it that way.
But let me show
you how this works.
In this case, I'm using the
push to talk, as I said,
because it's a simpler protocol
without the Hotword Library.
And could we get
this on the screen?
Can we get the device--
there, thank you very much.
OK.
How do you say, "nice
to meet you," in Korean?
GOOGLE: [SPEAKING KOREAN]
GLEN SHIRES: What
time is it in Berlin?
GOOGLE: The time in
Berlin, Germany is 6:50 PM.
GLEN SHIRES: Set
the light to green.
GOOGLE: OK.
GLEN SHIRES: Doesn't
show up as well there.
But maybe you can see here live
that the light turned green.
Make it red.
Oops, got to press the button.
GOOGLE: It's not raining there.
It's mostly sunny.
[LAUGHTER]
GLEN SHIRES: Make it yellow.
GOOGLE: OK.
GLEN SHIRES: There we go.
So this is demonstrating
the device actions,
which we're
previewing right now,
which allows you to
directly talk to the device.
So rather than, let's say if
I'm using my Google Assistant
on my phone, I
might have to say,
tell my oven to set
the temperature to 425.
If I actually go over to
my oven and then press
the button on it, I don't
want to say, tell my oven.
I just want to say, set
the temperature to 425.
And so what we've done is when
the device with the microphone
is listening, it
basically takes precedence
over all other actions.
So you can program
actions on Google
to do your own custom
actions, and then
when they're on your device,
you'd actually take precedence.
So you don't have to preference
it with, tell my oven to,
set the temperature.
Just say, set the
temperature to 425.
Let me show one more
that's kind of fun.
Play trivia game.
GOOGLE: You said
the magic words.
Welcome to game show
mode, my friend.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GLEN SHIRES: So you can see,
we play all sorts of audio
through it.
It's not just our favorite
lady, but it's not just
the Assistant, but
it's whatever you
want to do when you're
making your own actions.
You can create actions that
have all sorts of sound effects
and mix and match those.
GOOGLE: I'm the host
of this silly show.
How many contestants do we have?
GLEN SHIRES: So I'll stop that.
Actually, you know what?
I keep going back and
forth and I apologize.
There was one more thing I
wanted to point out on this.
GOOGLE: Sounds great.
Let's play five rounds.
Let's hear from you now.
I have some important
questions to ask.
Contestant one, can
you say, smarty pants?
GLEN SHIRES: So what
I wanted to point out
is there's two microphones
here, and I'm not
going to play the trivia game.
But I wanted to
point out the fact
that we work very well with
one or two microphones.
And I'll get to
that in a moment.
So the gRPC API is
a very flexible API
that lets you have
a lot more control,
and I wanted to run
through how the API worked.
First of all, if you want
to connect to the API,
you just create a connection
with a couple simple commands,
make a channel, gives
you a stub and then
you can call a service.
We have a service
we call Converse,
so we can converse back
and forth with the server.
Once you've set up a
connection to the server, what
you want to do is
configure exactly how
you want to send
audio to the server
and how you want to receive it.
In this case, we're
sending audio as linear 16,
which is plain old PCM.
Doesn't have to be compressed.
We do allow FLAC
compression, which
is a lossless compression,
which cuts down
the bandwidth by about half.
We're going to send it with a
sample rate of 16,000 Hertz,
and then we're going to tell
the server what we want back.
And in this case, we're going
to get OPUS_IN_OGG, which
is a nice, tight
compression engine,
and we'll say I have
a sample rate of 22k.
So that gives us some
better quality audio.
So we basically set
up a configuration,
and then we start sending
things to the server.
The first thing we send
is that configuration,
followed by audio.
So we're sending
audio in chunks.
Were streaming
audio to the server.
And then the server will tell
us when it's got enough audio.
When it has heard
the end of the query.
And then we can be receiving
the audio and process.
So when we receive
end of utterance,
we're actually going
to stop sending audio.
And then we're going to
gather the audio coming back
from the server
and play that back.
It also has a
microphone mode that
allows us to continue to talk.
So in other words, as you're
having something like a trivia
game, as you're
playing, you don't
have to keep pressing
the button each time.
When it asks you a question,
it keeps the microphone open
so you can continue.
Finally, I wanted to talk
about the two microphones
and the neural beamforming.
One thing that we do to keep
costs down in the client
is make it work very well with
either one or two microphones.
And with two
microphones, we do what
we call neural
beamforming in the cloud.
So that the cloud's optimized
for farfield recognition,
in other words, you can
be several feet away.
And it's very noise robust.
And we use machine
learning to process that.
So in other words, very
common in a household,
for example, that
you may be speaking,
there's a television, a
radio, other kids, dogs,
dishwashers all running
at the same time.
So there's a lot of noise.
But what we do is, on the
server we do all the processing
to filter that out.
So you don't need to have any
additional client processing.
Just send the two
channels directly up
to the server and we do the
neural beamforming for you.
So what this does
is it keeps the cost
to the client to a minimum.
So one thing I like about this
voice kit, and just the fact
that we have the SDK and
made it so available,
is that a lot of
people have started
using it in just the three
weeks that it's been available.
A friend of mine
actually told me
that his daughter
came to him and said
she wanted to be an engineer
and she wanted to make
a kitty that she can talk to.
And the amazing thing is,
she was able to do that.
They actually got together one
evening and built a voice kit
together, put together
the Google Assistant,
and now she's actually got a
kitty that she can talk to.
Which, when I sit
back and think,
when I was a kid
there was no way,
it was just a dream that I could
build a robot I could talk to
and it would actually
understand what I'm saying
and actually talk back,
it'd be intelligent.
Let alone the fact that I could
ask it virtually any question
in the world and actually
get a response, because it
would know the answers.
So it's really
inspiring to me that we
can inspire young
engineers, and I
hope that we're also
inspiring you to create
wonderful new devices.
Let me turn it
back over to Chris.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS RAMSDALE: Thanks, Glen.
Those were some
awesome demos and words
of inspiration at the end.
I like that.
So to wrap up here, when
we set out on this talk,
we wanted to create one
ubiquitous Google Assistant
experience that helped
you with whatever
you needed, wherever you need
it, whenever you needed it.
We've got Actions on Google to
handle the whatever, as well
as the Google Assistant,
but the Actions on Google
extend that Assistant
into other services
that you utilize in your life.
So we've got that
whatever cover.
With the addition of
the Assistant SDK,
we can handle the
whenever, wherever,
because we extend out
from just the Google Home
device or your Pixel or your
Android phone, to other devices
that you will have in your life.
And technologies like the Home
Graph and Smarthome agents
tie it all together
so you can have
a natural conversation with
those devices in your life
and feel very comfortable.
So I wanted to say thanks
for taking your time
to come out and talk with us.
We've got a couple next
steps if you're interested.
So first of all, I
want to reiterate,
we've got an Actions on
Google Developer Challenge.
If you sign up at
g.co/actionschallenge you can
register to win a ticket
to next year's I/O,
as well as over 20
more other items.
And beyond that, we've
got demos going on
and Sandbox B. I'll be there.
Glen will be there.
There's other engineers,
product managers and developer
[INAUDIBLE] folks.
So come check it out.
We've got a codelab for
some hands-on hacking.
We've got the
Assistant-enabled Mocktails
Mixer which I'll be demoing
throughout the afternoon.
And then we've got the
home automation session,
which goes deeper into that
Home Graph and Smarthome
agents at 4:30 with our
colleagues Mark and David.
And then obviously,
we have documentation,
Getting Started guides,
and technology to download
at developers.googl
e.com/assistant/sdk.
So cool.
Thank you so much.
And we'll take some
questions because I
think we've got
about 10 minutes left
if you want to come up and ask.
Thanks again.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]